what if you could use your nose to
snorkel or a brute a small tree or smell
water from several miles away
well elephants wouldn't be that
impressed they do it on the daily thanks
to what's inside their trunk if you were
to dissect an elephant trunk it would
actually look more like the inside of
your tongue than your nose trunks
tongues and even octopus arms are unique
organs called muscular Hydra stats that
means they're made almost entirely of
muscle and an elephant's trunk has a lot
of them about 40,000 compared to around
650 muscles in the entire human body
normally muscles depend on bones and
joints to move an exert force when we
pick up a dumbbell for example our bicep
pulls on our forearm bones and that
causes them to swing up around our elbow
joint but in an elephant trunk there are
no bones to pull and no joints to hinge
on the muscles take on that role instead
this makes trunks incredibly flexible so
they can move in all directions and all
those muscles mean they're powerful
enough to lift hundreds of pounds yet
delicate enough to pick up a tortilla
chip without even cracking it
but while trunks may be structured like
a tongue and function like an arm they
are in fact a nose and an exceptional
one an animal sense of smell is linked
to the number of olfactory receptor
genes it has an elephant's well they
have a lot of them nearly 2,000 more
than any other animal we know of
bloodhounds for example only have about
800 while humans have even fewer in fact
an elephant's nose is so good it can
actually sniff out bombs people have
reported that African elephants avoid
landmines in Angola and in 2015
researchers put it to the test
elephants were presented with a lineup
of buckets filled with different smells
including TNT the main ingredient
landmines out of 97 TNT samples
elephants detected all but one of course
their trunks didn't evolve as bomb
detectors they use their nose like we
use our eyes to find food and water to
avoid predators and to map out other
elephants
that's like walking into a family
reunion with your eyes closed and
knowing exactly where everyone is but if
you can believe it there are even more
tricks up there drunks when elephants
traverse deep rivers for example they
curve their trunk into a snorkel and
when bathing they can use it as a hose
or more like a fire hose with one suck a
trunk can pull in as much as 10 liters
of water and the trunks impressive
abilities haven't gone unnoticed in fact
if you stick a mirror in front of an
elephant one of their favorite
activities is to open their mouths and
check out the trunks let's admit it if
you had a nose like that you would do
the exact same thing
[Music]
you